hey what I saw Oh Walker here to talk
about venom man where do I start with
this okay I think I gotta come at this
from a couple different angles let's
just start off as a movie snacking
especially good reviews I was not really
excited to see this movie ah see if it
didn't have to do it for a job I
probably skip it you never know I think
the idea of doing a venom movie before
doing a spider-man movie is really weird
because you're just gonna look at all
the cool shit he does and say I wish
Spiderman was there to fight that but
he's not but okay Venom's a great
character I'm I read a little bit of
spider-man not a ton but the stuff I
loved reading was anything about this in
BO suit so him getting the black sues
memory game the black suit that whole
long process was great when venom came
along that was great loved maximum
carnage you know that stuff was so cool
so I know enough about you know Eddie
Brock and then immense stuff to know the
general gist and as a movie in general
to just taking out spider-man or how
well compares the comic or anything it's
just kind of generic bad it's pretty
much a run-of-the-mill action movie with
good performances actually all the
acting is legitimately good in this I
mean even when it's kind of goofy it's
goofy towards making the movie fun and
memorable and nothing really stands out
like super bad until the end until like
you get to the very end and it just gets
pretty damn stupid and I think what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna tell you what I
think of this movie and then I'm just
gonna go through what happens in the
film I'll say spoilers and everything
because I need to sort of go through my
head and be like wait did that makes
sense that that
did that add up to anything you know so
I'm kind of really curious if I Belize
and maybe I'll get stupid or the more I
talk about it
or maybe you'll be better unlikely but I
kind of want to run through it but
pretty much as a film the uh I feel like
this is a movie that got destroyed in
the editing because just from the first
few shots like it's edited kind of weird
like you see the shuttle crashing and
that's done fine then just crash
anything you just cut to like this smoke
and people like over the crash getting
stuff out and then lowering like the jar
with a little embryo in there a symbiote
or whatever I'm just like seem like have
a quick cut and then it cuts to like you
know this guy went 2d crash when did it
happen
oh the satellite is up there so well
when did that where'd the astronauts
wear the blah blah blah and you know
it's like one astronaut is alive who you
know Jameson okay but as a movie that
doesn't matter um but and then it just
kind of like the guys in the ambulance
and he gets up and possesses the
ambulance driver and the ambulance
driver just walks out the end you know
I'd like this is all in the first like
two minutes and it doesn't feel like
you're we shot that way it doesn't feel
like it was acted that way uh I don't
even know if it was written that way it
just doesn't feel that way and Sony
kinda has this long history of just
putting a million more thumb prints on
something when you know it's just one or
two thumb prints were enough and they
always want Southie cinematic universes
and it just has that Sony feel to the
whole thing it actually makes me really
nervous for that other spider-man movie
coming out the animated one which kind
of every time I see a preview it looks a
little better and then a little worse
and then like I keep going back and
forth between wow that looks awful wow
that looks totally different and amazing
so bla bla bla I'm worried now after
seeing so okay so it's basically if
you're thinking this is gonna be a movie
about venom the psychotic killer and the
split personality and going back and
forth it's real
not it's pretty much like supposed to be
the anti-hero but anyone he kills which
is maybe I think maybe one or two you
see and the others like he just throws
people around I don't even think they're
like indicating they kills anybody and
it's Tom Hardy again doing a great job I
like Tom Hardy because I can I can see
him like in five movies in a row and not
know I saw him he's one of those really
good actor he's Gallagher II uh Gary
Oldman that way or how giant Depp used
to be in stuff like that and after what
I like about him in this role is I
really enjoyed Tom Hardy but he he plays
characters he doesn't really play he
doesn't really give performances that I
feel emotional towards I don't like feel
you know I don't I don't feel much for
bein I I don't feel much for I don't
know the pilot in Dunkirk or something
like that honestly before this the most
afraid fell for him wasn't emphasis and
that kind of says something maybe I just
haven't seen him in the right thing but
most of stuff I see I see these
different characters you know I see Mad
Max I see all these and I'm just like oh
my god I didn't know that was him but I
never really feel for them this is the
first time I kind of got like oh my god
I hope this guy turns out okay I hope
nothing happens to him you know I I feel
bad for what he's going through so
that's good and if that's something I
want to see more out of Tom Hardy or Jim
maybe he has done a lot I just haven't
seen them I think he'd be really great
at that so I want to see even more of
that out of him and you know he plays
this investigative journalist on
something we don't know if it's TV or
the internet or what it is it's just sir
this Eddie Brock show and he goes in
interviews this guy this big CEO of
science or something this guy that Owens
everything who's a lot of fun I think of
I can see a lot of people not liking
this performance he's kind of like a
pretentious evil Steve Jobs kind of guy
he always has a speech and stuff like
that but he says it's so out of nowhere
and so manic and so strange so he's like
super energized a super young
to where it's like I felt it kind of
worked I thought they made it like kind
of distinct and stand out and I was
really excited to see these two together
cuz Tom already plays this you know
reasonably likable guy and then you know
this villain comes along just these two
very different eccentric personalities
and they're gonna do this interview I'm
like oh I can't wait it's only a minute
long and then they're just kept separate
throughout most of the movie and then
finally when they meet up again it's
like you know that now there's like two
monsters going around and stuff so you
don't really see much of them together
and that's that's a shame because I felt
like these two characters could have
been a lot of fun working off each other
you know very strange but very eccentric
and different but you know you don't
really get much of that so so Tom Hardy
gets you know he tries interviewing this
guy gets fired because he's asking too
many questions that just you know make
him look bad and stuff like that which
why would you hire this reporter who's
known for asking these incriminating
questions to get this interview to make
you look good and he gets fired and and
then it gets this suit and the suit
talks to him and you've seen the
trailers that you can do all the cool
venom II stuff you know shootout and
stuff and that starts out cool
especially like whenever something would
come out his body would kind of move
with it so I like that it isn't just him
standing there and this thing comes out
like it would kind of jerk with them
which I like but it from there the
action sequences kind of get worse and
worse the more and more kind of relies
on the suit stuff because the CG is not
very good sometimes it can be creative
but the best visual of the whole thing
like the thing I thought was the most
venom was this the face just comes out
like this long neck that just sort of
goes and talks to him it's got the evil
smile and it's just it's creepy and it's
great and I'm just like yeah that's
venom uh but from there it just kind of
turns into no here's how we act good
here's how we play nice here's how and
we don't want to see that from venom and
we don't want to see Eddie Brock as
a good guy or if if we do we want to see
like you know I get maximum carnage
where it's kind of like you have to the
Lions of convenience where you have to
join sides to defeat a bigger evil you
know like that's cool you know but you
want to dislike him you know it is kind
of like doing a Riddler movie and he's
the good guy you don't want that you
want to be the bad guy
so so pretty much again just quick
wrap-up here before I go into like what
happens in the movie and stuff yes or
again - spoiler territory it's a bad
adaptation of the comic just straight up
it doesn't go anything into the split
personality apart from him just talking
to this voice but you never feel like
it's taking over the rules of this thing
don't really make sense to say your room
I feel cold but like it seems like he
can just get rid of it whenever he wants
or he's asking like where are we going
where are we going it's like what don't
you know like even the movies bringing
up the plot holes there's a scene where
like this thing's let's eat him let's
eat him no we can't even and stuff like
that and his whole thing is staying with
him and yet his ex-girlfriend comes our
asses you need to go to the hospital and
the venom it's like I like her though
with her and it's like why he's gonna
get rid of it she's gonna get rid of you
take you to the hospital and everything
goes there and that's exactly what they
tried to do and they voice no no don't
do that no and it's like so and even the
damn venom voice at some point when
she's driving there is like you know
what you haven't apologized to her yet
you might not get another chance like
like at all uh which is a shame because
the voice is cool sometimes venom self
Kimmel Kandi's a lot of times when the
way he moves can be really dealing ways
climbing up buildings or just leaping
off into the water and stuff like that
that can be really neat but in terms of
what venom is if you're thinking you're
gonna get the cool villain movie you're
not gonna get that and as a movie itself
it's I mean there are some people that
went there to see it that we're really
excited I mean just you know I don't
think there are comic fans or anything
they just want to see a dumb action
movie and they they liked it for a
little bit but like you could just tell
any of the
they're they're kind of snickering like
what's gonna what's the like what's even
the evil plan like you know even they
couldn't get everyone's motivations down
because they kept jumping around which
we'll get to that a bit so it starts off
just kind of generic I feel like if
you're looking for just an OK action
movie with it with some good acting you
know not great act you and I can see how
Heath Ledger's Joker and this are
anything but I mean like you feel for
these people under there turning in you
know good performances and stuff you'll
get that for a while you'll get kind of
a gin you know anywhere from a generic
action picture to just a me action
picture you know if you really listen to
what they're saying in question what
they're doing you'll see it is not
particularly good if you just want to
turn your brain off and go in you might
like it okay and then why gets to the
end not only does the end just make no
sense and it's all this dumb dialogue
and everything but it's just even
visually it's an action sequence it's
like we go from these cool scenes of him
fighting people in his apartment and
cars and stuff like that where there's
like CG on him but they're really doing
these stunts and flips and stuff to just
totally CG I mean and it just looks
awful and nobody's like oh no what's
gonna happen it's just these generic
computer-generated sequence a it's like
you're watching a cartoon so yeah I
wouldn't recommend it I say if you're if
you're curious if you just want to see
you Tom Hardy as venom you just the
curiosity gets the best of you you
you'll get some okay things out of it
you'll probably be done by the ending
and not need to seek another movie
because they're they're filming another
one and again we'll get to that so yeah
I I say it's run-of-the-mill bad until
you get to the end where it gets really
pretty damn dumb not quite to the so bad
it's good territory either but I don't
know I gotta go through this movie again
and and see him and maybe I'll change my
mind so that's my general review right
there so now I'm gonna go into spoilers
I'm just gonna go beginning to end what
happens here that just so I can see if
this is
as I remember or maybe you see it as
worse or better or whatever so all right
so I got to the point where this one of
the scientists there says you know yeah
I'm tired this guy you you know we're
talking about curing diseases and stuff
like that trying to stop overpopulation
and stuff but he's gone mad he's just
throwing in random people homeless
people to you know to do the symbiotes
on stuffing that looking for a host and
says so they're looking for the right
host that's the thing you know where he
find this right host where this other
one called riot who I never heard it I
don't know that character and maybe it's
a newer character came along it's not
carnage but way for it pretty much like
you know gets Jameson's son because he's
in this for a millisecond and then gets
the ambulance driver and then goes from
like person to person so the right host
apparently is not that important unless
that's something about right cuz right
there's more powerful to me he can live
on a better host I have no idea they
don't explain any of it
but after rockets fired from his job
again just an example of the bad editing
it suddenly says six months later I'm
everything in myself I didn't need to
see that I could seen him going through
jobs and trying to find other work and
just some time pass you don't have to
say when this is and that especially
does it make sense because this riot
character took six months to get I think
that's right from Malaysia or something
like that just stayed in the same body
for six months just to get to the
airport for six months and then once
once he's at the airport he can suddenly
get on a plane and as a little kid know
how that works as a little kid just got
a plane fly to America find that I'm
like right away find the place that
makes this thing and I'm like what took
six months that makes no sense so so
while that's going on Brock breaks into
the with the scientists breaks into the
place they apparently have no security
cameras because they're like who did
this
this is the worst run science facility
like in the world cuz like you know the
scientist is like you know well you know
we have to do more tries on different
animals and hoses no no just jump right
into doing humans it's like well but we
we're not ready yeah it's like you know
don't you understand so much is on the
line and we never really know what it's
like the future is on the line it's like
think of you know your family and your
kids how are your kids and I can't he
says they're kind of creepy but it is
like what is the rush like this makes no
sense and nobody else has this thing
nobody's gonna beat him to it
so Brock breaks in and sees that there's
that we're kind of homeless people one
of them is somebody recognizes and it
tries to break her out this super
unbreakable glass apparently this super
powerful symbiote can't get out of but
like a fire extinguisher can and she
attacks him and the symbiote goes inside
of him and he's a good host for whatever
reason it never says if he's strong or
if he's healthy or if it's something
with the brain or it just says he's a
good host and that's why they're going
through so many people so they never
explain that and right away this thing
is making that kind of crazy and stuff
which again is kind of cool like well
where's where so it's going he's like
breaking in to see his ex-girlfriend you
know he's got the who of course is
dating somebody else now and is totally
nice and he said I got pictures here I
got picture oh my god I'm hungry and he
starts eating lobsters and then like
going into like the lobster tank cuz
he's warm and stuff like that he's he's
playing it great I mean he's playing it
right he's really got something going on
inside of him but then like it doesn't
continue through the thing like he's
suddenly he's not hungry he's kind of
more in control and he can talk fine
it's like why was he that crazy before
why was he that manic and then and then
then I can sense things like you know
the voice starts talking and it's like
don't open the door huh ding-dong and he
goes and nobody's in the eye hole he
opens it up and though they were the bad
guys coming to get him
and it's like what venom can sense that
venom can not only sense that there's
people at the door but he can sense that
they're bad people you know not better
hosts if I even says you're a good host
I'm sticking with you I can't get rid of
you I want to stay with you and it's
like what how do you know those other
hosts aren't good you have no idea um so
you know he max out these things we go
on this long action sequence that again
it gets kind of tall where he's on this
bike it has one or two coolest things
but it's like it gets old pretty fast
and well next one next so he then he
starts to talk this thing again this is
where it comes out it's nice to talk to
him like a little hand puppet which it's
actually cooler than making it sound and
so he goes and he tries to jump up this
building because again even though venom
says you're our vessel he's he's doing
this stuff he's dropping off like this
proof to the place he used to work at
you know the pictures and stuff like
that whether this evil scientist is
doing and why did he even decide to do
it he just talked to his ex-girlfriend
and like he discovered things are over
and so that's what convinced him to like
go after the scientist I don't get it
but so anyway so it drops off the stuff
and then comes across the SWAT team and
he knocks them all out and he's like
chewing on these gas cans and stuff and
again okay action scene and then the
ex-girlfriend comes and she's like you
know with this sees that you know Easy's
got this stuff or whatever and says we
need to go to the hospital now and he
invent homes like I like her go with her
like why so he goes in the car and he's
you know you really should talk to her
you might not have a chance you see my
people are gonna come and eat the earth
so you might as well talk to her and
it's just like the one what's this about
things eating the earth and what so you
know I really show apologize to you and
I just be like timeout what's this thing
about eating so he goes to the hospital
and again they want to give him my
casket and the things like no no you
can't do that no it's like you're going
to a hospital you actually did that
already with this thing I believe like
he already had the thing in his body
he's gonna go there again
so vannamei says we are been amazed adds
his name so it's like okay whatever
so they always call him venom and so he
gets this thing out just their little
hospital glass dork and stop him and Tom
Hardy's like eat but he finds out like
somehow this thing was I don't even know
it was controlling his heart accelerate
his heart he's like I can fix it I can
fix you I healed your arms and your legs
I can fix you which good point I mean he
did you know basic oh you were trying to
kill me yeah I turns out I didn't need
you it on this is supposed to be like
the friendship ripped you know part of
the movie where they they you don't need
you and then turns out they do but it's
like I did they form a relationship and
just sort of seemed like he said you do
this I don't want to do you're doing
this and then sometimes he'll turn to
venom and sometimes he won't it doesn't
even seem like there's any understanding
of who's in control or why so then it
gets out through the vents because da
you know as soon as you get this thing
would you be okay we gotta keep this
thing in there we gotta yeah Deana uh
and then it goes into the body of this
little dog which I got excited for I'm
like what venom doors gonna be at the
mask this crazy venom animal - what
you've also think you like yeah why
doesn't this thing thing could go inside
animals like giant and like bears or
lions or shit like that why is it going
in humans you're like that doesn't even
make sense but but it's in this dog and
all you see is the eyes kind of flicker
and that's it we never see venom dog so
disappointed cuz this is like love those
two little purse dogs and I'm just like
but they don't take that opportunity but
you have no stupid go full stupid but
okay so then riot makes it all the way
to the the evil scientist guy that have
a corporation whatever possesses him so
it's a okay now they're kind of working
together on this evil plan to I guess
bring these other alien monsters down to
eat the world cuz that's what he wants
like
his motivation is like in both their
motivation honestly is done kind of in
passing it's like a sentence it's just
like yeah he wants to control the
population he wants to stop to make
people being in the world and start a
new earth like I don't even know those
were the words it just went so fast
where I was like I've kind of an idea
what he's no I really didn't I really
did not have an idea of what his plan
was or why he wanted to do it he would
just make these really long speeches
that tend to ramble on which I thought
was part of what made him funny what
made him kind of entertaining and even
serve the threatening level of him was
that he could be kind of charming and
matter-of-fact but you know like just
saying you know a thing about your kids
how are you kids you know it's like just
that alone it's like that's kind of
creepy he just said that so mad or
effect but you know he meant something
really menacing there but I have no idea
what his evil plan really was or his
motivation or why oh really this other
thing so so then this they said the get
Brock and they're gonna go and they're
there they're gonna shoot him he finds
out that you know he's got riot in him
and they're working together and and
just before they shoot him which I like
this scene where he turns her I tries to
grab the gun and the guy knocks him down
he's like I guess that's why you're
especially it's like I thought I just
you always see that movies when they
always grab the gun and they have it at
it's just I want to see that fail once
and it finally failed I was happy friend
it was totally points to which I kind of
like I like that just he tried it it
failed it's just like oh yeah you're
like a specialist like I'm just a
schmuck so but then venom comes as the
ex-girlfriend which again looks cool
it's like oh wow now here's this giant
like venom woman it's like you know
Heather Brock it's got that big smile
and everything grabs and like starts
kissing him and as it kisses him it like
goes on to him now and I'm just like
okay that was kind of cool but then not
only doing that see the dog but we don't
see how this thing like you know it
treats her she's talking to it and stuff
like that does they have a different
voice in her head or just two of the
teeth boy because it sounded kind of
different coming out her you know I'm
like that would have been
you know do something like the mass
comic where it just kind of jumps from
person to person maybe but like we just
get that one scene and that's it uh
there's no talk about like how good the
power feels or like it's addictive or
and like none of that like we get it
that it's like literally a couple
sentences at the end and that's it and
the to the ending a myth so so okay so
venom is like no you must stay here it
gets ugly like why does he care for her
there is no reason and then he's going
in I swear to god this is the dialogue
rescue me oh man this just gettin to me
man skin to me like and that this is
like the third act you know so this is
where like the real stupid stuff happens
he's in Brock now he's like why why are
we trying to stop riot from going up
into space and bringing all these little
alien monsters try the world and stuff
like that he's just like you know well
truth is on my planet I'm kind of a
loser like you that's a lie venom food
that dude right there it's kind of a
loser where he comes from that's what I
want with bat yeah what thinking like
all these symbiote people like going
around just picking on poor little venom
with like his little dorky glasses and
maybe he had like bigger but teeth what
he wasn't honest in Theo de jugar he's
code you know I'm trying to do my man so
there's that there's that dumb thing and
then he's like well what's the other
reason he's like because I like you
Eddie why they have no chemistry at all
except Venables they do something and
he'll do it we haven't even really
gotten into the you can kill people
here's how to be an ethical person
here's good things about humanity is
that like none of it it that's done
before the end
so there is no connection no ethical
anything with them but but I like you
Eddie so they go to this rocket blasting
off I mean like it's literally blasting
off and like Venom's there it's like
it's riot the chances of defeating him
are zero okay you're not a nerd where
you come from cuz zero you defeat him so
it must be more than zero but and
there's plenty of things I can destroy
him because they say these loud
frequencies can destroy me and fire
funny because he says these really
specific settings you know these
frequencies you know sent really high
can destroy me and fire just just fire
them so take it guess how he dies so the
dial is literally so riot is there he's
about to get on the ship and then venom
comes to stop him and he's like you know
venom get on the ship he's like no I
won't let you destroy this world they
die that's the dialogue like
transformers longer dialogue than that
it really felt like Optimus Prime and
Megatron talking to each other so they
do this really bad CG fight which again
just looks super fake looks like a
cartoon at some point they both lose the
the symbiote suit but but then the bad
scientist guy CEO gets it back stabs
Eddie Brock oh no like through this and
he falls down his eyes are open
he's dead guys he's dead he's not dead
it comes back and brings him back to
life I was shocked too but apparently
he's not dead and he comes back to life
so Ryan goes in the spaceship after
everybody's killed he kills everyone
setting this ship off it's so
controlling it monitoring whatever he
just killed everybody it's just gonna
Auto go off I guess go to its
destination or whatever without a pilot
or anything
and so riot runs the ship just like as
is taking off like he goes and opens up
the door that's that's totally how it
works you could just it's like a kitchen
door you just open it close it done it's
not like it's space it's not like you
can get sucked out with the tiniest
miscalculation oh just open it close if
you're in uh but then venom gets on and
like you know cuts the ship causing it
to explode and that sets it on fire and
then that I was like good boy venom
makes this little parachute while also
on fire it looks exactly as silly as it
sounds and he goes in the water cut to
your mrs. Doubtfire ending where they're
just in San Francisco there's Tom Hardy
there's the ex-girlfriend and they're
just talking like yeah so never saw him
again
no no never saw him again yeah huh so
did it feel good yeah yeah felt pretty
good like you're wrapping up a rom-com
and they're just talking about it Andy
you know it's just like you know he
removed the time when he kissed me yeah
I remember
dude you oh I don't know but but it did
feel good and he's like would and she's
like the power he's like oh yeah yeah
that's what's talking about - oh yeah
yeah so that talk about like just
feeling that power and that diction that
even spider-man 3 really delve into -
beyond it I mean not oh it's gray
they're stupid dance sequences stuff but
in a dress there's an addiction to it
he's just in that one word the power and
he confuses it for the kids so then you
hear the boy still in his head so it's
like uh it's like a buddy
road trip movie like oh oh here we go
again and I swear to get the point where
I just lost it
I can't embarrass myself because like
the tide she goes I'm really sorry about
venom this actress is credit she says a
totally straight face totally like no
like I'm really sorry and she deserves
an
Oscar just for saying that line without
cracking up but nobody nobody looked at
that shit that might sound fucking
stupid I'm sorry about that okay so so
she gets up and she's like wait it's
something still there no no I gotta go
and you can see she's almost like he's
not dead is she like she doesn't quite
say that but it's like it's like what
step away from it so then he starts
walking down the street sailing well
look you gotta learn how to treat people
you gotta learn there's a right way to
treat people or is the wrong way to be
PLO only go after the bad people what
are the bad people well you can't just
tell but something that should have been
like beginning of the second act end of
the first act conversation again this is
how you form their connection they're
doing right before the credits and he
goes into this um not qui I like a
convenience store that again I'm pretty
sure is that night now it shows him
walking during the day as soon as he
goes in this place it looks like it's
night but may it's just the tinted
windows I don't know but here's this guy
that always comes in like just
constantly robbing and it's just all
those things alright so it's like the
second time in the movie and they can't
make up if he's like if it's like
payment for like whatever insurance or
protection you know that thing or if
he's just straight up holding the gun
robbing or he's like I'm here to collect
yo you better give me the money but it's
like if this is an ongoing thing and he
needs to bring a gun don't you think
some security would be up there she'd do
something different but he and if this
is an ongoing thing why would he bring
the gun why would he like hold it on
that so baby
what do you increase the chance of
getting caught there if he kept doing
this anyway so he turns into venom again
we don't even see him transform he's
just already venom and he grabs him they
say if you ever come back here again I
will eat your face and you'll be just
this lifeless turd blowing through the
wind or something
venom says turned which is really weird
and then he says on second thought and
you see him like he's about to eat them
Lyla you see his mouth like ether
amaura that kind of thing but then it
just cuts to him shrinking back and him
and the convenience store owner they
they just have a normal conversation Oh
what happened well you know I get sick a
parasite like and you have no idea of
that guy is in his stomach or not like
at all because when he leaves there's
nothing there on the ground or any
there's no blood no nothing or did he
just run away like we don't know like if
he said just run away why the anti he's
going to eat the camera you we never see
him run away and then like as the run as
he's walking off and the cameras like
you know backing out showing San
Francisco he's a parasite
did you call me a parasite will you
archival parents are you take that back
no no I'm not gonna apologize like like
this was a stupid ass comedy the whole
time and that's that's where it
officially ends it then plays a venom
rap like it's the 90s and it's and then
of course we get the credit sequence the
end credits sequence which is kind of
what you'd expect but even just doing
them they just do it so stupid so he
he's in a prison now because I feel like
every single one these after grad
sequences has to be in a prison now in
maximum security in the deep dark place
where there's like things peeling off
the wall and stuff like that only where
they hold the really bad people the real
criminal masterminds it says he wants to
see your Prague is like hey red you got
a visitor you read the comics you know
what this is so they go and there's this
big giant cage guy in a straitjacket
bright Ronald McDonald hair awful wig oh
and it's Woody Harrelson which I'm like
it's a weird choice but okay he can be
funny he can be pretty cool and
literally the first thing he says is
I'll spare you the traditional serial
killer thing of all the question
and stuff like that and he doesn't he
just coach days of doing the serial
killer thing like I will find a way
oh you think you're so big oh you think
you're so and it's like he he says he's
not gonna do a cliche which his movies
already full of them and then he just
does the cliche and like I don't even
know what he called him there I guess
Eddie Brock put him away or something
like that I don't know and you know he
says let me tell you when I get out of
here there's gonna be carnage superdumb
close-up like see what we're doing
wait what the performances are good
great good no you know what they're
great that woman had to say I'm sorry
about venom totally straight-faced
totally serious and mean it oh so yeah
the really dumb crazy shit like are you
fucking kidding me stuff doesn't happen
until the end and even then it's only
it's just it's kind of question it's
like why would this person do this why
would this person do that it's not
really like it's bad dialogue but it's
not laughably bad you know it with the
exception of you get on the ship know
then die you know like that's kind of
funny but yeah it doesn't get like super
super stupid until the end everything
else is just kind of like weird
motivations or no motivation no real
connection and yeah it just kind of bad
editing you know like I really feel like
there were scenes chopped out that would
have explained a lot of this more but
even if it did I feel like this is just
a weird idea who wants to see a venom
movie before a spider-man and venom boy
we watch these spider-man venom
fighting and then he gets his own movie
you know if you got into a van Damme
movie really go into the split
personality really going to what makes
him interesting don't make it like a
buddy cop movie
that's all I felt like with this movie
and so it's something where it starts
off like that like maybe they're gonna
do it and then they really don't they
kind of turn into a dumb comedy action
picture where it really should have been
like a horror comedy or comedy horror
action maybe even a horror comedy just
horror and there somewhere you know okay
then that's a creepy idea you know and
once in a while you get some imagery
that that's like the comics like I said
that um but yeah it just just really
didn't work yeah looking back it's still
it's really still just that third act
and it's like the choices they make
beforehand are stupid and don't amount
to anything but at least his giving you
the impression it might go somewhere and
that just doesn't so but it's it's not
one of those I think is laughably bad
until a couple scenes near the end so if
you're look you're hoping it's gonna be
one of those words oh it's so bad it's
good it's really not um but there's if
you're looking for a movie to rip apart
if you're looking for a movie to nitpick
and stuff like that I mean you'll find
it you will have no shortage I know
there's people who look for that and I I
get that I totally get that you want
just find a movie to be angry at it you
son of a bitch I mean it's like I get
that I totally understand that but and
yeah there's a lot to kind of get pissed
off at in this movie but it's it seems
like such a waste anyway like it doesn't
seem like it's I mean Sony's sort of
mucked up spider-man so many times and
so many weird ways that's kind of like
of course this would be the next thing
they do which again it makes me really
nervous for that spider-man universe
movie because to me that looks really
good it like it looks really different
really unique I kind of like bringing in
these different spider-man's and like
and they just get so odd like with the
weird pig and the anime girl on stuff
I'm just like what like that's so
strange
so out there I'm actually kind of
excited for it and the style is grand I
love the animation I'm just
oh I'm hoping it works it really hope it
works but I don't know if they're making
them like this like then I'm not holding
high hopes so here here's hoping because
that's because that looks like there
might be a fun movie especially if it's
trying something legit different with
this whole spider-man idea I mean that
is just so strange and so bizarre you
know at least it isn't just oh Peter
Parker gets fit by the spider again
that's to stop these villains we've seen
a million times you know it seems like
it's really doing something kind of
unique which I'm kind of down for but
yeah I don't know man I don't know well
we'll see what happens so that's my
review I review and also told you the
whole movie pretty much but yeah let me
know if you let me know your level of
dislike I doubt many people are gonna
like this movie but I'm curious if
people just diehard hated or if they're
just like am it's just kind of dumb I
think if you're a real venom fan like
real spider-man fan you're gonna really
hate this movie but if you're just like
I just wanted a dumb comic-book movie
and so which I was almost going in with
the idea of you just see it as kind of
dumb like that's pretty much what I got
out of it so that's about it I will see
you next time take care
you